dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr. Khurana if I here when I
was growing up IQ tests were created by
humans to test the intelligence of other
humans if someone told me just 10 years
ago that algorithm will create IQ tests
to be taken by other algorithms I
wouldn't have believed a word of it yet
just a year ago scientists at deep mind
created a program that is able to
generate a large amount of problems that
test abstract reasoning capabilities
they are inspired by human IQ tests with
all these questions about sizes colors
and progressions they wrote their own
neural network to take these tests which
performed remarkably well how well
exactly in the presence of nasty
distractor objects it was able to find
out the correct solution about 62% of
the time and if we remove these
distractors which i will note that are
good at misdirecting humans too the AI
was correct 78% of the time awesome
but today we are capable of writing even
more sophisticated learning algorithms
that can even complete our sentences not
so long ago the open AI lab published
GPT 2 a technique that they unleashed to
read the internet and it learned our
language by itself a few episodes ago we
gave it a spin and I almost fell out of
the chair when I saw that it could
finish my sentences about fluid
simulations in such a scholarly way that
I think could easily fool a layperson
have a look here and judge for yourself
this GPT 2 technique was a neural
network variant that was trained using
one and a half billion parameters at the
risk of oversimplifying what that means
it roughly refers to the internal
complexity of the networks or in other
words how many weights and connections
are there and now the Google brain team
has released Mena an open domain chat
bot that uses 2.6 billion parameters and
shows remarkable human-like properties
the chat bot part means
piece of software or a machine that we
can talk to and the open domain part
refers to the fact that we can try any
topic hotels movies the ocean favorite
movie characters or pretty much anything
we can think of and expect a bot to do
well so how do we know that it's really
good well let's try to evaluate it in
two different ways first let's try the
super fun but less scientific way or in
other words what we are already doing
looking at chat logs
you see Meanor writing on the left and a
human being on the right and it not only
answers questions sensibly and
coherently but is even capable of
cracking a joke of course if you
consider a pan to be a joke that is
you see a selection of topics here where
the user talks with Mina about movies
and the bot expresses the desire to see
the grand budapest hotel which is indeed
a very human-like quality
it can also try to come up with a proper
definition of philosophy and now since
we are scholars we would also like to
measure how human-like this is in a more
scientific manner as well now is a good
time to hold on to your papers because
this is measured by the sensibleness and
specificity average scored from now on
SSA in short in which humans are here
previous chatbots
are down there
and Mina is right there close by which
means that it is easy to be confused for
a real human that already sounds like
science fiction however let's be a
little nosy here and also ask how do we
know if this SSA is any good in
predicting what is human-like and what
isn't
excellent question when measuring human
likeness for these chatbots plugging in
the SSA again the sensibleness and
specificity average we see that they
correlate really strongly which means
that the two seem to measure very
similar things and in this case SSA can
indeed be used as a proxy for human
likeness the coefficient of
determination is 0.9 t6 this is a
several times stronger correlation than
we can measure between the intelligence
and the grades of a student which is
already a great correlation this is a
remarkable result now what we get out of
this is that the SSA is much easier and
precise to measure than human likeness
and his hands used throughout the paper
so chatbot say what are all these things
useful for well do you remember Google's
technique that would automatically use
an AI to talk to your colors and screen
your course or even make calls on your
behalf when connected to a
text-to-speech synthesizer something
that Google already does amazingly well
Mina could really come alive in our
daily lives soon what a time to be alive
this episode has been supported by Lamba
if you're a researcher or a startup
looking for cheap GPU compute to run
these algorithms check out lambda GPU
cloud I've talked about lambdas GPU
workstations in other videos and I'm
happy to tell you that they are offering
GPU cloud services as well the lambda
GPU cloud can train imagenet to 93%
accuracy for less than $19 lambdas
web-based IDE
lets you easily access your instance
right in your browser and finally hold
on to your papers because the lambda GPU
cloud costs less than half of AWS and
aja make sure to go to lambda lab
dot-com / papers and sign up for one of
their amazing GPU instances today our
thanks to lambda for helping us make
better videos for you thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time